a woman couldn't even vote before
We're coming up on her first woman president soon
It's only gonna make her believe stronger that she's gonna be the first woman in the NBA
It's funny cause all the girls look at her like oh, she's only [nine] [Ten] years old
She goes out there, and she makes a fool out of them. If you come up on her she's gonna go by you.
She was a girl playing against boys, and she was dominating. It was just so natural
So I just let her fly
I'm Jaden Newland and I am a  point guard for the Downey Christian schools varsity team
Downey Christian  is a private school. We don't have a governing body saying
oh you have to have these stipulations to play long as you can perform and
You know excel in the parents of the child are okay with it. You know you [can] play we had a few good girls
We needed another ball handler. [so] I was like let's use [Jayden]. You know let's see what she can do
Well you had a couple people that were for it and a couple people that
Disagreed too much attention. She can get her [letter] be a child, but you know it's [everybod]
[oh], and says what she's passionate what she wants to do it, [so] I'm gonna take it from her
People say oh she's only on the team because of her dad. [I] don't score a point for her
I don't pass the ball for her. I don't dribble for her
I don't play defense for her so for this a that's like really funny to me I
Love Jayden play ball at like three years old at the YMCA just her skill levels
Amazing James [meas] different the most tenure girl because old tenure girls aren't doing what she's doing. [I] can't imagine
Jayden playing against girls her age it would be crazy. She always played up or against boys well playing against boys
It wasn't hard they think that I wasn't good. So they just let me go
But after that they started dean up on me, and I'll still score her development has came from always playing with boys
She's probably bored our whole life, but one time she's played with girls
And when she's played high school so once she played high school. She said wait a minute. This is easier than I thought
When I found out I wasn't a varsity and third grade
I was scared, but after that I got I got used to it
Isn't it was easy for me after?
Some of the girls on the team at first they were just confused like they were expecting a [ten-year-old] to play on their team
But she sees the court well she has reins when she crossed his girl when she made girls fall
That's when we're like wow she can handle playing on the varsity team. [I] work hard because I want to be though
That's what I ever play basketball, and I want go to uconn and then go to wNBa
but I want to be a first girl to go to the NBA [I]
Love her words at the she's one of the hardest-working people. I know out of boys and girls
I think she's gonna be the best you [ever] play basketball
She works so hard, and it just didn't happen like she worked for what she has she was born to play basketball
You know I'm the lighter on her that I am Julian
But I'm lighter on her cuz maybe she has she is Daddy's little girl
So I don't push her as hard as I push [Jill]
But when I don't she's the one [that] comes to me how come you don't have me do this
But you have julia do this so she's like that always asking me to do more so she has a tremendous work ethic
That's only built from within and that's when things Aidan has something you cannot teach on a Sunday
We want to me and my husband want to relax they want to go to the gym
It's like wow we get a break but no
It's the passion and love for that game
The work that [we'll] take to get there is
Everything because you got to work hard if you want to be the best
And if you wanna be the first girl to go to the NBA that's a work really hard
I don't think there's been a thought, but her mind. She's going and I believe it
She could be the first why not
She always tells me and others that she'll be the first woman in the NBA and I think it's a not a goal
You hear every little [girls] say, but I feel like it can happen
For Jaden to make the NBA dream a reality she has to one not lose focus
To continue to work Harder even harder than what she has been 3 continue to believe we know what's going to happen by somebody
For why not Jaden? I don't feel pressure because I want it
And I know that it will come true